hi I'm Joe cools from the land of
enchantment the state of New Mexico Joe
if we were to travel to Albuquerque what
should we do while we're there give us
some local travel tips well Nava Kirky
there are many interesting places to
visit such as petroglyph national
monument Coronado National Monument
sandhya ski resort historic old town
Kirtland Air Force Base the National
atomic museum the Rio Grande River
Balloon Fiesta park and museum the
Indian cultural center the set india in
Manzano mountains see below national
forests and isla de and Sandia publis if
you could trade places with any famous
explorer or world leader who would you
pick and why well for an explorer I
think I picked Christopher Columbus
because he explored the unknown and
proved that there's something out there
were seeing he discovered new lens and
brought many unknown things back to the
people of Europe if someone gave you a
free ticket to travel anywhere in the
world where would you go tell us what
you would do while you were there and
why you picked it well I think I'd go to
Italy because there are many famous and
historical places tues either and have
some distant relatives there too in is
alia I would visit Venice where I could
see st. Mark's Square and the Grand
Canal in Rome I wouldn't visit the
Colosseum the Trevi Fountain the
catacombs the Roman Forum the Vatican
and the Tiber River in Naples I would go
see Mount Vesuvius Pompeii and the Isle
of Capri in Pisa I would see the leaning
tower of pizza and in Florence I would
go visit the doma hey nat geo do you
know where the world's longest
continuous Travis from its highest point
it takes seven point eight seconds to
fall to the ground and it has many
interesting rock formations around it
such as fish rock canon rock and totem
pole rack
you